[Music]
overview of just how we think about
fleet management and what it means to
build a modern scalable device
management solution Marcus is going to
talk about Chromebook applications and I
think we have a really unique
applications platform on Chromebooks
where we try to bring the best of a few
different worlds together from the web
obviously to Chrome extensions and
applications as well as Android apps and
a few other things that Marcus is going
to give a preview of and then Derek will
close us out by talking about how
SoulCycle has grown its business and
it's technology together over time and
the lessons learned along the way like
most sessions here at next we do have a
Dory Q&A available so if you'd like to
ask any questions please just go into
the app and you can tap on our session
and tap on Dory QA we'll take some
questions at the end and we have
microphones here as well for live
questions all right so let's get started
so one of the things that we really
believe in is that organizations need
cloud native tools and endpoints and we
think this because we've talked to many
different organizations of all shapes
and sizes that are rapidly moving to the
cloud and so their employees experience
now is really centered on apps and
devices we see a Forrester study that
showed that employees are now using on
average 22 cloud-based apps and three
devices so these are mission-critical
tools for these employees to do their
jobs and we have a real opportunity to
make them better
what we found though as we've talked to
a lot of organizations is that managing
and scaling and deploying these
platforms is actually quite tedious
today and it doesn't scale all that well
and it's not because people are making
things over complicated and I think when
we dig into the processes that
organizations are using all of them
makes sense all of them have genuine
business reasons behind them and nobody
is trying to cut out any step of this
process but I think the important part
is that it's not very easy and it's not
very scalable and we can do a lot better
the other thing is it's only getting
harder
so where is at one point maybe you were
just taking a device and imaging it and
making sure the operating system and the
software was up-to-date and then you
just kind of send it out into the field
and maybe you see that device again in a
few months or a few years you know now
we're doing everything through the cloud
and so we're thinking about not just
devices and users but also applications
also peripherals like printers networks
security monitoring reporting etc and so
there are so many new layers to the IT
puzzle now that we have to pit fit
together and fit together in a way that
feels cohesive and that presents an
understandable IT policy to our
employees now of course we're adding all
of these layers at the same time that
we're adding just an unprecedented
number of devices into the mix so we're
making it both more complicated and
scaling it in a way that we haven't seen
before and so I think at Google we feel
that we have the opportunity to help
improve this situation by focusing on
reshaping enterprise computing and the
reason I say computing is that on the
chrome OS team you know we build the
chrome operating system and when I say
cloud native what I mean is that the
Chrome operating system really came out
of the Chrome browser project which is
of course people's first sort of
introduction to the cloud that's your
viewport into the cloud but if you
expand the Chrome browser and all of its
principles like simplicity and speed and
security and you turn that into an
operating system all of a sudden you
have a device that's not just cloud
ready not just cloud was added on top of
something existing but actually cloud
native meaning it was built for that
purpose it was built with the
opportunity to do OS updates in a cloud
native way for instance to do policy is
in the cloud native way to do management
in the cloud way to cloud native way as
well as applications so in addition to
the operating system the product that we
have for realizing this vision of cloud
native computing and and endpoints and
tools is the Google admin console and so
if you're using G suite or you're using
mobile device management this is the
same console that you're already
accustomed to
and this is where you can go to manage
every single layer that we talked about
in that previous slide and this is also
where you can go to manage your chrome
devices and chrome browsers and so when
we talk about Chrome Enterprise that's
sort of the umbrella product that
encompasses all of these different
things we have fleet management we've
got tools we've got the application
experiences and all of that together is
what allows you to bring chrome into
your enterprise in a cloud native way so
I'm going to talk real quick about fleet
management and so I'll cover a few
principles that we've learned over the
years from talking to many different
organizations all shapes and sizes all
industries verticals etc the first is
that fleet management should be simple
and so what I like everybody to picture
here is put yourself in the seat of an
airplane cockpit and you're looking
around and you see all of these hundreds
or thousands of different controls and
buttons and surfaces and imagine you
don't know what most of them do right
would you look at one and say hmm I
wonder what that one does you know we
hope that people don't fly planes that
way but of course that's how a lot of us
learn technology is we just kind of
experiment and see what all of these
things do but hopefully not so much in
an enterprise context where these things
can have real consequences for our
employees so I want to point out the
airplane analogy because I think you
know you also won't want to fly a plane
that didn't have those controls either
so simplicity is not about taking things
away but it's about making sure that you
don't actually need to be modern or
monitoring and modifying each of those
things every time you know I think the
realization that we had was that we can
kind of do things better we can raise
the baseline of what organizations have
as their baseline level of security and
policy and management just because there
are a lot of commonalities across all
types of organizations and then you can
spend the time customizing things to
your exact needs
of course simplicity is also only
getting harder so with the cloud native
device we can now add so many more
policies than we've ever had before and
so whereas we started with just an
full of policies we now have hundreds
and hundreds of different ones this
includes things even down to the level
of hardware so things like two-factor
authentication things like TPM firmware
updates things like processor threading
and so I actually hope that nobody in
this crowd has ever thought about those
things because they're probably not poor
drivers to what your organization does
but at the same time it's helpful to
have all of those things have all of
those controls ready and that's the type
of area where we can make a big impact
by making it simple the other principle
that we've heard is that device
management needs to be scalable so with
respect to this beautiful animating gear
here that actually means more than just
the raw scale of the number of devices
you have of course we're familiar with
all sorts of scales of devices from just
a few to a few hundred thousand but
scalability also means adapting the
fleet management tool to your type of
organization so we work with
organizations that have one admin who
does things part time every few Fridays
because that's what the organization
needs and we work with organizations
that have multiple admins with tiers of
access different privileges between them
specialized knowledge in devices or
networks or security needs around
auditing and compliance and making sure
all those processes work well and those
two organizations don't necessarily need
the same management experience in fact
they probably need different management
experiences and so scalability is not
just about making sure that it goes no
matter how many devices you have but
that it adapts to the actual needs of
your organization and lastly our goal is
for device management to be insightful
so we really want to kind of turn the
table so that you're not just thinking I
want to manage my devices but actually
my devices can provide something back to
me my devices can provide some kind of
information so imagine that you have a
device that is checking in all the time
and then suddenly it just falls off the
map
you know was that because that device
got lost or stolen or maybe the
employees on vacation right it's not
necessarily a bad thing but it's
something that might be worth your time
to investigate and so insightfulness is
about providing that kind of proactive
information so that you can pay
attention to the right things because
even at the scale of a few dozen devices
it's just impossible to keep track all
the time of every single thing that's
happening in your organization so we
need to have a tool that will actually
work with you to help make a lot of that
easier so let's get down to the brass
tacks of the things that we're actually
working on the the first one is speedier
administration next is OS update
controls you know we could probably have
a whole session just on OS update
controls we hear a lot from folks that
this is really important and it's also a
big opportunity we're having a cloud
native device allows us to do a lot more
things it's not just about customizing
the version but it's also about how do
you scale and deploy and rollout and
apply updates even OS rollback is
something that we've heard a lot about
and that we're working on now so OS
update controls are a big area of focus
for us
reporting obviously is something we
talked about with the point about
insightful and then browser management
is one I really want to draw your
attention to we just announced on
Tuesday the full availability of Chrome
browser cloud management and so if
you're using Chrome browser in your
organization which if I were a betting
man I would say you probably are this is
a way for you to bring Chrome browser
into the cloud and actually manage it
through the same admin console where
you're managing all of your devices and
so you can do things like set policies
deploy apps and extensions manage
extensions by permission if you want to
and even get some information back about
what types of extensions your users in
your organization are using so if you're
not yet on fully cloud native devices we
understand that that takes some time but
browser management is a great way to get
started today
with having some of the magic of the
cloud management in your organization
so I'm gonna go through a couple of real
quick demos here one thing I want to
point out is that if you are familiar
with our Google admin console you'll
notice that these look a little bit
different and that's because we're
working on a full visual refresh and
adding a few new features and making it
a lot faster so this stuff may look a
little bit new that's intentional and we
have a number of trusted tester and beta
programs if you're interested in trying
it out so for the first quick demo we're
gonna do a device search and disable so
imagine that you have a fictional
organization and we've got an employee
named Sandra and she's leaving the
organization so what we can do is just
go ahead and search for Sandra's name
and we're gonna find all of her devices
in the device list she has 15 of them so
she must have been productive we're
gonna just go ahead and disable them and
what you might catch at the end there is
that we're actually putting a message on
the device itself that says you know
property of organization please return
to this address that kind of thing and
so this is a great example we're having
a cloud native tool on a cloud native
device really worked together well
because we have this just built into
every single Chromebook that you're
managing and when you think about things
like information security and data
lockdown and whatnot this is a really
really easy and integrated way to do all
of that stuff you don't need a third
party software you don't need to buy
anything else it's just part of the
Chrome enterprise product next is log
capture so we understand sometimes
people need to capture logs about their
devices for any reason and with chrome
kiosk devices you can do just that so
I'm going to go ahead and capture logs
here this is actually gonna run in the
background so if you want to go to
somewhere else in the admin console and
do another thing while it's running you
can do that of course once it's done you
can go ahead and just download the file
so we'll give you a zip file with a
bunch of different logs from the device
we can open up the event log and a text
editor find anything we need and again
this is not the only log capture system
out there but it shows the power of
having things that are really fully
integrated having a cloud native device
with the cloud native management working
together really well
the last thing I'll mention about fleet
management is again that we are running
trusted tester programs on these things
all the time
and so if you like anything you're
seeing so far or you'd like to try them
out and give us some feedback we'd love
to have you do that please just come see
us right outside the door or after this
and we'll be happy to take it out down
your information and get you set up with
that I also want to mention if you're
using the trusted tester program and you
send feedback to us and you're wondering
where that feedback goes it goes to my
inbox so we are really truly reading
every single word that you send us we
care a lot about building a tool that is
is actually simple and scalable and
insightful and we can only do that with
your help so thank you very much for
that next I'm going to invite Marcus up
onto the stage to talk about application
management so Franks makes for a great
first overview of the admin console and
also thanks for everybody in the
audience for having me especially after
the big event yesterday evening so I'm
Marcus another give a short overview of
the Chrome OS app ecosystem in the next
minutes and thereby especially focus on
the questions how can we manage these
apps basically the Chrome OS app
ecosystem is driven by one core idea
that's very inherent to Google we want
the open web to succeed so imagine a
world where basically all your apps on
the cloud so all the apps you are using
for your business or your entertainment
our web apps in this world you could
basically work everywhere use every
device login to your favorite web app
and you are done you could just be
productive or entertained wherever you
like
and this being driven by this idea we
have basically these advanced
technologies of Chrome OS in the center
of our app ecosystem however we are very
aware that basically editors of today is
it is not possible to realize every
application as a bad application because
not every system capability is actually
available as a bad capability so that's
the reason why we have these native apps
on the left side
namely Chrome apps and Android apps um
I'm sure some of you know that Chrome
apps are already deprecated on Windows
and Mac and that we invest more and more
basically into the integration of
Android apps into the Chrome OS
operating system however both of these
native apps have the advantages that you
basically can use also some capabilities
on Chrome OS device and on the right
side you see the Linux apps here so we
are better aware that not every
developer and not every user for Chrome
OS device will use Linux so basically
Linux apps are great way to support
developers and Chrome OS devices so to
conclude with Chrome OS we don't want to
build another gated ecosystem but we
want the reps to succeed and we do this
by native apps at once web technologies
and Linux apps on our devices I want to
walk food is free pillars now step by
step and especially start with the
Android apps here so when I was at booth
the last two days basically a lot of
people were coming and talking to me and
they were surprised that actually
Android apps are running on a chrome OS
device so yes it's possible you can push
me basically just go into the Play Store
on a Chrome OS device and install nearly
every Android app you like there are
some restrictions and some of them
require camera at the back of your
device so these ones don't work but
nearly every everything works basically
and if you look at basically the app
ecosystem that enables this for you you
can for example use every communication
app you like so if you don't like
hangouts for whatever reason you can for
example use Cisco jabber on these
devices you can use cisco webex you can
use Skype and basically to connect to
your colleagues you can also use for
example Ray's system close and
networking apps like VPN to go to login
basically into the corporate network of
your company and for example the ones of
our colleagues at f5 and you can also
use VDI apps so for example you can use
Citrix VMware Microsoft RDP all these
apps are basically part of the Play
Store as of today
and fifty CI ups you can use for example
applications that are very computed
computation intensive so if you want to
for example design 3d things on your
device like using a Katia software it
probably doesn't make sense to carry
this big notebook that is needed to
execute CATIA all the time around with
you you can't just run this in the cloud
and stream it why are we di it really
was and actually the cool thing is that
for all these Android apps they are
coming out of the Play Store that means
that basically the Play Store already
filters for harmful apps which helps to
increase the security of your device and
it's an admin you can even go one step
further and write the specific apps for
your users so basically you prepare a
set of apps that your users should
install and you can even go one step
further and say okay I want to install
this and this app by default for a
certain user so that's called force
install in our admin console and this
allows basically the user to use these
apps at the moment where he locks in
into his Chromebooks these apps I'll
install instantly and you can use them
just by default we will see this later
on okay but let's move to the core what
is basically the web apps here can we do
everything without web apps as of today
norm if you walk around and you see
basically Gmail Google Drive G speed you
can have the impression that it's
already possible but it sure answers
actually it's not possible as of today
because some capabilities are still
missing and to basically close the gap
between today's web apps and the native
apps that we have on the system as of
today you have free clear initiatives
that are described on this slide for
example we have one initiative that has
the target to basically provide all
api's and capabilities to support
applications in the web so this includes
for example system notifications
basically every app should be possible
to erase this and notifications every
app should be able to create sockets or
an app should be able to access the file
system so we are adding these
capabilities step by step not only on
Chrome OS but in general 50 Chrome
browser and
of platforms out there and the second
service that we have progressive web
apps especially desktop progressive web
apps which allow to install apps offline
web apps off line on any device that you
like and the first step is that you can
basically use webassembly to execute
your C++ code which helps only wanting
to microwave apps from one platform to
another but on the other hand and speeds
up a lot so we have the example of figma
here so figma is quite a nice app
basically to design Android apps and you
can run it completely in the browser
it's using web assembly based on C++ if
you want to know more about these
progressive web technologies I invite
you to visit this session later on today
from my colleague Thomas MD to a free
I'm developing on Chrome and it's at
11:40 and the last but not least we have
Linux running on Chrome OS so as I said
it's targeted to s4 for developers
if adi p/n running there you can
basically execute your Linux apps and
they up quite sandbox from the other
apps on the Chrome OS device and
February's been set up that we have
running here where we see a lot of
Corrections for example that you run
Android studio and a chrome OS device
and then you can basically test the
developed Android apps also directly on
this device that's actually very used
however to be honest like the Linux and
equation so crostini is still at an
early stage so it runs on nearly offer
all of the interface Chromebooks
our the admin console management here at
the moment the state really can only
turn it off on so we are planning to add
these capabilities later on this year
to conclude the app section I want to
highlight that basically all of the apps
are kept separated wire sent boxes so
you notice probably very well from your
Chrome browser so if one tab crashes not
the whole browser's crash but only the
step is basically shut down and
basically every tap is absolutely
isolated from the other tabs in your
browser the same holds true for your web
apps for Chrome extensions for Chrome
apps and Android apps on your Chrome OS
device
let's now move on basically to the
management and if you look at management
we basically have three main ways to
manage Chrome or as apps and let's start
with the first one this is basically a
new allowed user to do what you like so
basically you trust the user to execute
apps you don't influence it a lot and
this set up is probably very favorable
if you have like administrators in your
user base and who you don't want to
restrict a lot because you you think
okay they know what you do
I grant them all provisions second way
to manage apps is why a black listing
and white listing so black listing and
white listing works quite nicely for web
apps it works for Chrome X apps
extensions and also Android apps so the
ideas that you either like exclude
specific apps from being installed on
the user's devices or your whitelist and
so you basically say okay the user has
the right to install this or desert app
and therefore you can basically create a
fairly good set of apps and basically
restrict the user to what he can do on
this device and third step I already
mentioned it as to force install apps on
a device so you can basically say this
app should run on the user user's device
and every time he locks in immediately
you can like combine these like you can
wipe with certain apps and force and
some other apps and what's actually
pretty cool and what I like about the
admin console here is that basically the
admin console has quite smart defaults
so for example if you are an enterprise
and you start the admin console with its
defaults you will see that Android is
activated by default with all apps
available to users so basically if you
do don't do anything users and the
position to decide which Android apps
they want to install which makes quite a
lot of sense if you look at an
enterprise user however if you are like
a school so you have basically in
education license the default setting
for schools that Android is first shut
down and even if you activate it it's
activated in a managed mode which means
that you basically whitelist the apps
that are available for these students
and the reasoning behind this is quite
clear and we don't want to play students
games during the lessons and
because nobody would listen to the
teacher any longer so basically the
admin console helps you quite a lot to
have the right defaults here and not to
do the wrong thing by any chance okay
let's maybe have a look at some examples
here that we brought from the admin
console so the first one is the
integrated atlas so all the apps that
you have an Android on Chrome OS are
basically listed in this integrated
atlas so you have two chrome apps chrome
extensions and Android apps in this list
and you can easily see what apps are
installed on your device and you can
easily search for them so we will see
that we basically filter first for all
Android apps and then we look for the
Google Drive app in this example so we
go into this list we click and type
click on Android and then we have the
Android lists apps or if you just type
Drive they're usually basically the
drive apps that are available for your
user base and the second example
actually as this one so here we
basically want to add a new Play app on
the users devices and we don't want to
just edit we want to force it solid and
pin it pinning means that basically the
icon is shown at the lower bar on the
user's devices so that he can easily
access it and if you want to do that
basically you go to the same list you
click on the plus button down there then
you go to the Play Store and then you
search search for the sheets apps inside
this Play Store click on it and click
select and from this time on you will
have to play at the sheet set in your
app list and now you can basically
select what you want to do it you can
allow install it but you can also force
and solid block it pin it or force
install and pin it and that's what we do
here all right this already concludes my
part and now I want to hand over to
Derek who gives us basically yeah a true
use case yeah explains this example and
yeah that's
morning everyone good to see you all so
bright and early on Thursday morning
thanks Max and Marcus and Google for
having me here today
so like all the stuff that you saw in
the slides previous I'm really excited
to talk to you about how SoulCycle use
basically a lot of the technology that
you saw in transforming all of our
Studios to pixel books I want to give
you a little bit of history first
so SoulCycle opened in 2006 we had one
studio 30 bike and in the 13 years that
we've been open we've now renounce 92
studios during times of rapid growth
that could mean 12 to 14 to use per year
and super excited to say that we'll be
opening our first either in London in I
want to say June each studio has seven
to eight classes per day and that makes
about 600 rides I'll leave you guys to
do some napkin math on what that looks
like and then to make all that work from
a tech side we're looking at 2500 staff
across the United States and Canada and
500 computers across the fleet so when
we started to look at replacing our
existing technology for new technology
we came up with a few rules and a
challenge we wanted our new technology
to prepare for innovation in the future
so basically that means for
point-of-sale running transactions day
to day for retail transactions and also
whatever is in the looking glass of
technology we also wanted to be able to
allow our studio staff to interact with
our riders in a new way so for any of
you that have ridden a SoulCycle before
we've got a front desk with our studio
staff behind it and we wanted to be able
to look at what technologies could we
use that we could send our studio staff
into new areas of our studio and start
to look at different types of
interaction with our riders
this is the interesting one what we
wanted to do what to try and find a
single tool that looks after the
management of our Hardware of our
applications our users without a lot of
like the traditional glue that comes
with running an enterprise suite of
hardware and end-users specifically we
want to look at modern identity platform
security features like two-factor
authentication we wanted to look at an
easy way for application administration
and also to tie that in together with a
single Hardware management platform and
of course we had a good mix of aging
computers out there so we decided how do
we can replace that in a quick and
simple way that doesn't end up with a
mix of hardware in our Studios over time
thankfully we've been PCI compliant for
several years now and in choosing our
hardware and we wanted be able to make
sure that we could maintain our PCI
compliance but also to see if we could
reduce what that foot problem would look
like over time as with any challenge
comes a couple of rules one each studio
must be upgraded within two to three
hours we have a nice little gap in
between our morning classes or even
classes we wanted to make sure that we
could rip out the old technology get new
technology in there but more importantly
prepare the studio staff for that new
tech so that when the next ride check in
comes along they already feel
comfortable with the operations that
they need they always feel comfortable
with what a device may look like both
from logging into the device using our
software and primarily focusing on the
right interaction as opposed to how do I
use this thing
this is probably the most important part
making sure that our studio staff feel
good about what they're about to do
changing technology can be really really
intimidating for people don't live with
it every day this was one of the things
that I thought about the most okay
taking all of the the challenge and the
rules into consideration we started to
look around at a mixture of tablets
laptops devices do we look at replacing
our existing technology with the best
and breed in in that line we've been a
gmail customer since I want to say 2006
or wasn't there we decided that the best
the best move forward was to leverage
what we are already used what I use is
already using with Gmail we've got we
decided to look for Chrome enterprise
and for deploying pixel books at all of
our Studios with chrome enterprise as
you saw in the previous slides we're
able to take a lot of the organizational
units and the policies that we could
associate with those organizational
units to identify applications to
associate applications to those specific
users so that we could tailor their
environment of their desktop to
precisely what they needed to do to do
their job the dust with pixel books we
decided to go for pixel books because of
ultimately their form factor and their
aesthetic I don't know if you for those
who have books of books right now
they're pretty slick looking devices but
and also they you can use them in laptop
mode tablet mode and I'll show an
example later of how we're using them in
all their different forms
in moving to a chrome enterprise and
full pixel books in all of our studios
we decided to also move a lot of our
traditional file servers over to Google
Drive and team drive this meant that we
would be able to unify we'll be able to
get some of our enterprise can uses that
were on more traditional devices and
increase the communicate the
collaborative function productivity of
of Google sheets Google and notes and
Docs and share that with our studio
staff for printing this was an
interesting salt so we decided to go for
we looked at some hard web based devices
that basically use Google Cloud Print
which was pretty good we ended up using
a mixture of Google Cloud Print devices
Google Cloud Print printers but also
there's a the Windows cloud connector
that we all that we ran on we ran on our
traditional print servers thankfully we
were able to maintain our peace our
compliance pretty stressful thing to
actually get done but what I wanted to
share with you is just a couple of
things that made that happen for us
trusted apps via the Play Store with
trusted apps we were able to essentially
prove the integrity of those
applications with Google asset
management auditors like to know that
you know where your stuff is so so a lot
of the reporting tools that we were able
to use helped in our in our compliance
finding there G suite IDP using
two-factor authentication for as part of
the users security orders it also really
liked
and a couple of other things so if any
of you had to deal with PCI compliance
before for your internal security scans
were there footprinting the devices
themselves and doing security scans very
nice to know that there were not many
open ports on a pixel book unlike a
traditional computer where there's
usually a fairly a myriad of open ports
most important that together we sent our
guys on a studio tour so we have a
fairly small lean team broke them out
into smaller into regions so we took
California a Central East Coast were
able to send one one person to each
studio and easily go through the upgrade
from our traditional computer pixel
books this is Las Vegas to do as we want
to walk you through what you're seeing
right here so on this is a front desk
here where we've got pixel books that we
use for point of sale and for booking
and then you'll see on the right-hand
side they say this is a pixel books
running in tablet mode that we use for
digital signature right a waiver
application so when a rider enters the
studio if they're brand new we can get
them checked in at the front and they
can just walk around the side and then
go sign a digital waiver and go and ride
but also because of the way that pixel
book was now that we're looking at books
are books in different iterations we can
send them out to the front of the studio
run retail you know kind of use them for
any kind of application that we see fit
there's a few things we learned from all
of this that I wanted to share with you
listen to your users I think everybody
when you're looking at replacing new
tech or putting in new tech you you
think you know what your users need we
spent a lot of time sitting without with
people in corporate office and in our
studios asking them questions about what
their workflows look like
what are they doing from day to day what
problems do they have with what they
have what they have right now and how do
we go about fixing those in finding
those souls be creative sometimes I know
I've been and I've been working in tech
now for 20 years sometimes there's an
expectation on how to go about doing
something right I need this application
that does that I can fix this by doing
that this is an opportunity or what I
learned was let's rethink it again from
and looking at some of the five familiar
on things like is there an Android app
that could actually solve this problem a
little better
do I look at reaching out do I look at
replacing this happen tirely where they
web app all of those things and lastly
reach out to Google talk to your reps I
don't think that we would have been
anywhere near a successful or admit as
quick as we could have been had we not
spoken to all of our reps about how do I
make team drive work with pixel books
how do I make how do I do this thing
with a policy that makes that thing work
I would have scratched my head for an
awful lot longer had I not been for the
help of Google and one hand it back to
max and Marcus to Q&A thank you so much
[Applause]
[Music]